it's moms night out for Amal Clooney  [Music]  the 39 year old human rights attorney  stepped out for a rare ladies night to  celebrate the unveiling of the Gianni  Versace archive collection by William  vintage and far fetch in LA on Thursday  here's a mall looking glamorous next to  her gal pal actress isla Fisher who  rocked a little black dress naturally  George Clooney's wives did not  disappoint with her fashion ok great  taste all eyes were on a mall as she  limited gold from her metallic cocktail  dress to her matching clutch and high  heels the new mom was definitely  camera-ready for the evening one thing  certain a malls post baby body is  incredible after welcoming twins Ella  and Alexander back in June last month  George told ET how the newborns already  have their own distinct personalities  starting with his son literally just  sits these she's very elegant all eyes  she looks like a mom thank God  [Music]